nearly a hundred percent of the people
balloted in those four regions uh that
are occupied by Uh Russian soldiers
voted in favor of joining Russia I think
it was always as far as most people were
concerned a foregone conclusion uh
Russia called it a referendum most of
the world called it a sham this is a
vote that's taken place really uh under
the barrel of a gun the areas that these
votes are taking place aren't secure as
I was saying they're occupied by Russian
forces and now really we see the pretext
uh for Russia annexing those territories
that's likely to be the next step
remember what we saw in 2014 there was a
similar vote in Crimea and then uh Putin
moved in to Annex those territories
we're expecting the same thing here
certainly the British defense Ministry
says that on Friday When Vladimir Putin
addresses the Russian parliaments it's
likely there'll be a vote after that uh
on annexing those territories and it is
an escalation because what it means is
as far as Russia is concerned those
territories become Russian and under
Russia's military Doctrine it means that
they can be afforded all of the
protections with all of the military
Arsenal including nuclear weapons that
Russia has at its disposal and we heard
from a former Russian president Dimitri
Medvedev today who reiterated what we've
heard from Vladimir Putin himself that
yes it is possible if those areas come
under attack that nuclear weapons can be
used for protective purposes so a
massive escalation I suppose it just
really adds to the sense of crisis